uh mike tyson always describes
um how he found like dmt
yeah did you ever get into any of the
hallucinogenic
side of things ayahuasca yeah so
ayahuasca is something
you do you did ayahuasca yeah me too
yeah i really want to do it yeah
it's an experience i hear you gotta have
a shaman and like it's helpful i think
it's better if you have a shaman and i
say do it at least
how many times have you done it i've
done it seven times i say
do it at least at least four times
because the first time a lot of times
it's
just getting your bearings but you got
to do it a couple times
did you um do it like did you go to
costa rica or
like where were you at i did it um i did
it in southern california this
there's a shaman from hawaii that
he would come here every year for six
months and he would do
pretty much every every weekend he would
do a friday saturday wow
um and so i did it with him a couple of
times i have another friend in topanga
uh who has ceremonies at his house and
did it a couple times but i would love
to go to
the amazon and do it i heard it's
hardcore there but but i want to
want to have that experience they you
know i had a friend of mine who did it
who
was addicted to cocaine and uh you know
had a
issue with you know sleeping with every
woman he met and
gambled like a crazy person and he did
two days straight
and it like changed his life he said it
was like doing 30 years of therapy
it shows you stuff but the truth is you
have to be ready to you have to be ready
you got to
want to see that you got to be ready to
see it but it shows you stuff
yeah what's do you remember the craziest
thing uh that you got out of it or that
you saw while you were
while you were on eyewash because i i'm
really curious into trying it
so for me you know i'm more kinesthetic
so it was more the feeling of it
in in when you drink the drink like the
experience was you can feel
like going into your stomach and like
pulling like
stuff out of your body and then most
people
purge and so when you go to ayahuasca
you know you sit down
in your spot and they give you like a
bucket
they call it purging because it's not
really puking because you're not
supposed to eat
you're not supposed to eat that going
into it yeah and so it's really
it's stuff like it's coming out of your
mouth it's coming out of your eyes
sometimes coming out of your ears did
you
did that happen to you yeah yeah wow
yeah um
and and i you know i had like i don't
know if it was
past life stuff but i had you know
images of being like a
native american um a native american
warrior
and and having to choose between um
going to war and and going to train with
the shaman
you know um and that's kind of that's
kind of how my life
has kind of been you know where i did
the warrior football player thing
now i'm kind of moving towards the the
shaman wow
yeah someone uh my friend said he felt
he he said there was a lady
like a voice her whatever he was saying
right
yeah and he was like um he was like
there was like trauma that i had as a
child i don't even remember
but it was it was holding me down and
without me even knowing it and he was
like it was almost like
they committed surgery on me yeah and
they cut it out of me yeah
yeah that shit's crazy did you hear like
a lady or like because i
i've heard that multiple times from
people that there's like
you know some something that's talking
to you talking you through it or like
so yeah so i haven't heard a lady but
but you know for me it's an ayahuasca
um an animal will come like a wolf came
one time
uh in a uh a ryan a white rhino came
another time
wow um but you know it's it's kind of
that same state that you experience
when you daydream or even sometimes a
night dream yeah yeah you know
that's yeah and it shows you it shows
you stuff
it has did it change you it did it did
you know
but i've been doing this work for a long
time like meditation like doing a lot of
retreats you ain't new to this
yeah exactly it ain't on yourself so
when it comes up it's like okay
okay okay this is this is what's next
this is what i'm moving through
right right right that's [ __ ] wild
man yeah you got to do it man i know i
know i need to
one of my friends has someone in malibu
that does it yeah but i definitely i
want to do it like
so make sure i'm with the right person i
mean the group the group you deal with
is extremely important